ومعنا الان من فيينا
وهو المدير التنفيذي للمعهد الدولي
للصحافه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد مارفتش في
الحصاد كيف تلقيتم خبر تمديد اعتقال صحفيه
الجزيره
اعتقد انه امر مشين تماما ان يتم
احتجاز وتوقيف وحبس صحفيين لاكثر من ثلاث
سنوات ومن دون ان تتم محاكمتهم فقط يتم
توقيفهم بشكل مستمر والتوقيف في مثل هذه
الظروف يعني حرمانهم من العداله لان تاخير
العداله يعني الحرمان منها ونفهم ايضا ان
هؤلاء الصحفيين يعانون من العزله ومن
التعذيب هذا امر سيء للغايه والمعهد
الدولي للصحافه الذي يمثل صحفيين محررين
يطالب السلطات المصريه باستمرار باطلاق
سراحهم وهذا الامر استمر على مدى ثلاث
سنوات هل هناك خطه مثلا معينه تنون
تقديمها او
موقف جديد من جانبكم
اعتقد ان هناك حاجه لان تكون هناك حملات
مستمره وثابته وهذا ما تقوم به منظماتنا
ومنظمات الاخرى نفهم ان السلطات المصريه
اطلقت سراح احد زملائكم في وقت سابق من
العام الماضي اذا هناك شيء من التقدم مما
يدل على ان الضغط والحملات تؤتي كلها
لكنها يجب ان تستمر ولا تستمر على مستوى
منظمات المجتمع المدني فقط كما نحن لكن
يجب ان يتم على مستوى سياسي على مستوى
الدول والحكومات لتطالب بذلك لان الصحفيين
في كل مكان بالعالم يجب ان يحظى بحريتهم
ليمارسوا عملهم فان المدير التنفيذي
للمعهد الدولي للصحافه من فيينا شكرا
جزيلا على وجودتنا